santo iddio mi che che puzza di morto
che c'è qua dentro io ci devo entrare
che ci sono i ragni lega perché devo
fare ste cagate è una cosa bella di
questo video è che avrò gli occhi rossi
per tutto quanto il tempo è la cosa fa
molto vampiro quindi ancora più alloggi
sono un bambino non mi scorre il sangue
sono mi scorre sangue non mi si alza
l'uccello ma questi sono problemi di
edward cullen non miei grazie si vede
perfetto che bello per tutti ragazzi
benvenuti questo video sono fa vj ed
oggi siamo solo speciale 666 video che
sarebbe 666 che sarebbe il numero di
scarpe di valigetta predire i ragazzi
che ho avuto far per questo speciale un
po strano ho voluto fare una specie di
top ten dei videogiochi horror più
spaventosi che io abbia mai giocato è
una cosa puramente soggettiva ragazzi
quindi magari voi preferireste altri
horror piuttosto che quelli che vedrete
però questa è una cosa mia quindi non
cagate un cazzo e quindi niente ragazzi
direi che possiamo cominciare con la top
ten degli horror più brutti più belli
vabbè partiamo e basta
primo video dei ragazzi cry offrire un
vita game che non ho mai finito perché
mi dava dei problemi all'avvio del gioco
però mi è bastato un solo episodio per
prendermi lo spavento in assoluto più
grande che mi stava imprese in tutta la
mia vita ed è esattamente questo dico è
tantissimo la cosa c'è una ics in fondo
cazzo come ci arrivo da [ __ ]
ma che cazzo era un culo cosa cazzo era
quella roba vede temi ragazzi non è
stato facile dormire nei giorni
successivi sette dei maledetti a
consigliarmi sta roba
[Musica]
[Applauso]
alla posizione numero 9 ragazzi troviamo
the house del primo flash game horror
che io abbia mai fatto sul canale è un
tecnico ambientato in una casa
abbandonata dal 1973 è stata abbandonata
senza apparenti motivi
io sinceramente i motivi ce li vedo
buongiorno sigrun cazzi direi che hai
detto bene zio da che porca [ __ ] però
preferirei dormire in questo ripostiglio
di merda che entrare lì dentro credete
alla posizione numero otto ragazzi
troviamo i'm scared che è un videogame
horror italiano non mi ricordo molto
bene la trama ma mi ricordo benissimo
che a un certo punto del videogame
iniziavano ad apparirmi messaggi
psicopatici sul mio desktop come sei
videogame stesso avesse preso possesso
del mio computer
beh hai raccolto cuore
si no come perché mi sa che sul gioco
c'erano questa è una cosa prima
attenzione il solo le pronuncia
all'arrivo e white face sorretta alla
posizione numero sette ragazzi dredd out
che è un videogame horror indonesiano la
protagonista si chiama linda che di
lingo non ha proprio un cazzo e si
ritrova in una città dove vorrebbe
trascorrere le vacanze con gli amici che
porchia di quella [ __ ] se facevamo
le vacanze in un tombino era meglio
iniziando a sentire rumori bruttissimi
non fosse normale
ok garmin compimenti zia bravo prossima
volta trivago sta minchia
una spuntatina ma solo dietro è proprio
davanti il ciocco lo voglio come prima e
poi tanto s'è mosso qualcosa
continuiamo che è meglio alla posizione
numero sei ragazzi e monde e slip sera
nei panni di un bambino che a stento
riesce a camminare quindi ottimo per un
videogame horror dove spesso bisogna
muovere il culo
in questo caso il pannolone cosa cazzo
cazzo via negozi veloce tra tutti i
videogame horror questo è quello che ho
trovato più poetico ed affascinante
perché non ci sono troppi gems kers ma
l'atmosfera è veramente paurosissimo gli
abbia riaprì di prenderti per ultimi
sì sì sì no no no no contrae a mi ha
preso è la posizione numero cinque
ragazzi penombra penombra è una trilogia
creata dagli stessi creatori di amnesia
e la fiction al games ed è stata la
primissima serie horror con cominciato
sul mio canale proprio la prima in
assoluto e ho impiegato più di un anno
per finire tra l'altro chissà perché
l'impiegata cazzo sta facendo no no a
[ __ ] sei un testa di minchia
ambientata in una base abbandonata in
groenlandia in mezzo al niente ed è
stato divertente quasi come andare a
mirabilandia fatti groenlandia
mirabilandia
mi sono chiuso con un [ __ ] mi sono
chiuso come un [ __ ] alla posizione
numero 4 agassi alien il sole show è un
videogame horror che ambientato quindici
anni dopo film di alien film famosissimo
di ridley scott
la protagonista è ripley una grafica
aggiungerei che si reca nella stazione
spaziale di sevastopol per recuperare la
scatola nera e per scoprire come
realmente morta la madre è ovviamente
che cosa ci trova lì dentro
poi ci voglia ragazzo diciamo non la
madre o sera la madre senza trucco che
fa
no no no fuori dai [ __ ] affetto
vorrei che a trovare casa e veloce la
rivolta alle l'ultima volta perfetta
siamo arrivati ragazzi alla top free di
questi videogame assurdi belli carini e
divertenti il cazzo sono né mix che fa
facciamola partire mentre che cerco le
cuffie che è meglio meglio così
alla numero tre ragazzi troviamo proprio
lui fa united freddy's che è nato
esattamente un anno fa e che nell'arco
di un anno sono usciti ben quattro
capitoli di questi video game
praticamente youtube è esploso con di
video sul suo gioco nell'ultimo periodo
continua a non capire perchè continuate
a chiedermi di farlo madre fa le pale
thor
sappiate che vi odio a morte ragazzina
in compagnia di siete riusciti a
consigliarmi il videogioco che mi ha
scassato le cuffie alla posizione numero
2 show on the grudge la protagonista una
[ __ ] di nove erika yamada che se
mettevamo lacca al posto della diesel a
cavalcava pure valentino che alla
ricerca del suo cane che è scappato in
una fabbrica abbandonata io il cane
l'avevo rinominato fuffi e continuavo ad
insultarlo perché mi faceva a rischiare
la vita in questo posto di merda mi sa
che avevo anche ragione
ok andiamo avanti porca [ __ ] porcata
no no no no no no no no no no no vabbè
ma si può uscire non va non vorrei mai
andare gli assi di cristo no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no merda a me
dopo indietro va indietro indietro
corri male destro idiota thor di corpi
dai corni calmissimi ok
porca [ __ ] [ __ ] bomberone rullo di
tamburi dove mi ha [ __ ] rullo di
tamburi bravo mio lavoro e lago sta
facendo il viso bravo
qua chi è outlast ci mancava questo è un
videogame horror non l'avreste mai detto
che ambientato in un ospedale
psichiatrico sperduto nelle montagne
degli stati uniti d'america e si svolge
appunto a mount messi il protagonista si
reca sul luogo perché detective
mettiamola così che va ad indagare su
fatti che accadono in questo posto non
l'avesse mai fatto porca [ __ ] pre va
bene premio tieni premuto si va beh lo
sa
diciamo che al tas è stato proprio alla
recisione delle volte in cui io non
registro perché magari devo raggiungere
un check point per iniziare il video e
nei momenti in cui non registravo
ragazzi mica gaveau addosso che se
registravo quelle reazioni pure usciva
fuori un'altra serie di altri veramente
fuori di testa sto gioco vi ricordo che
tremavo mentre chicca oi tasti sulla
tastiera è veramente è stato pazzesco
regala pazzesco dove cazzo sapevo mi
avvio quanto sono stupido allora secondo
con sé già passo già posso fare già
posso fare corri corri mi avete detto
dio mio santo mi avete detto che non
devo girarmi quando corro io cosa appena
fatto donna in questa classifica che ho
fatto non ho messo due titoli che
secondo me non hanno una posizione
perché sono due titoli troppo
particolari per essere messi in una top
ten
e sto parlando di amnesia the dark
descent has lander mentre gli occhi
rossi i due videogame horror che hanno
popolato di più negli anni in cui
youtube ha avuto il boom di
visualizzazioni in generale quindi
troppo particolari permessi per essere
messi in una top ten qualsiasi quindi li
ho voluti discostare da tutti gli altri
ma sono stati importanti anche per me
perché ad esempio slider me nel primo
videogame horror che io abbia mai fatto
su youtube in generale ancora non aveva
aperto il mio canale quindi anch'io
peccato che cosa bella che vi porta nel
cuore un maniaco pedofilo senza faccia
che i ragazzi questo è stata la top ten
grazie a dio è finita perché mi sto
veramente prendendo male qua dentro a
rilassarmi ragazzi nei momenti morti ho
dovuto scoppiare questi cosi però il
video vi sia piaciuto ragazzi è una cosa
un po diversa dalle cose che faccio di
solito ma niente spero vi sia piaciuto
ugualmente dentro questo ragazzo io
uscirei da qua un mi piace per gli
scoppiati v che ancora non sono morti
però moriranno presto e che i ragazzi
spero che vide vi sia piaciuto ma se le
cose visto che siete tanto mi piace
anche a voi di facebook e condivido
trascrizione siti strategici vediamo non
possono video qua dentro c'è un
telecomando
non c'è un telecomando non c'è un cazzo
qua dentro c'è uno stereo e 10 prefetto
che vediamo non prossimo visto i ragazzi